PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
These are the famous dots.
So you just have to say how
many dots there are.
BRADY HARAN: Two.
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
Two.
That's very good.
And you're quite quick.
Now the next one.
BRADY HARAN: Six.
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH: OK,
you're accurate there, but
you're a bit slower.
Well, I've been particularly
interested in the last few
years in dyscalculia, which is
a congenital condition that
affects somewhere between 3
and 6% of the population.
And what it means is that
they're very, very bad at
learning arithmetic, at least
learning it in the normal way.
And this seems to be a
lifelong condition.
We've met a lot of adults who
have this condition, adults
who are very successful
in other branches--
other walks of life.
Walks of life that don't depend
very much on being good
with numbers.
I mean, they could be
filmmakers, TV producers.
They could even be science
journalists.
They're not going to be terribly
good at doing the
maths for physics.
Well, it's like dyslexia in the
following way, that it's
something that you're meant to
learn at school, and that
unless you have special
help, you're not going
to learn it at school.
It's not exactly the same as
dyslexia, though it's often
called dyslexia for numbers,
because dyslexia is a problem
in reading.
But in fact, it's really a
problem of language, dyslexia.
So you have a particular problem
with analyzing the
sounds of language.
And that's really what prevents
you from linking
letters with sounds,
particularly for an
orthography like English
orthography, where the
relationship between letters and
sounds is not particularly
consistent.
BRADY HARAN: What's the
difference between someone who
has dyscalculia and someone
who's just a
bit rubbish at math?
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
The difference between
dyscalculia and just being
rubbish at maths is that lots
of reasons for being
rubbish at maths.
My own excuse is that I didn't
have a very good
math teacher at school.
And I didn't like him.
I didn't get on with him.
I've had to try desperately
to make up for that since.
For example, you might miss
a lot of lessons.
And since math is a kind of
cumulative subject, unlike
history, then if you miss a lot
of stuff, it's very hard
to catch up.
Dyscalculia can occur in people
with high intelligence,
good memories, who go to school
every day, have really
supportive backgrounds.
And yet they're unable to do
what everybody else in their
class can do--
do simple arithmetic.
So there is a difference.
You can often spot a
dyscalculic-- though these
aren't formal tests--
in lots of different ways.
For example, they have great
difficulty in remembering
telephone numbers.
They have difficulty in
remembering any numbers.
So they often are going to use
the same PIN, when they
shouldn't, for lots of
different activities.
They're very bad at shopping.
So actually, one of the first
developmental dyscalculics we
came across was in prison.
And he was in prison
for shoplifting.
Why did he shoplift?
Well, because he was too
embarrassed to go to the
counter, because he didn't know
how much money to give.
He didn't know whether he was
getting the right change.
So shopping is an area which
is really difficult for
dyscalculics.
They also have trouble
with time.
It's not that they can't
estimate intervals.
It's just that they're not very
good at the numerical
side of it-- working out, for
example, what time they have
to leave home in order to
get to somewhere at
a particular time.
We know that there's a
particular part of the brain
that seems to be involved in
very simple number tasks.
So for example, here in the
parietal lobes of the brain---
this is the back of the brain.
This is the left parietal and
that's the right parietal.
We know that these areas are
critical for just enumerating
the number of objects
in a set.
One of the things that
we now know--
this is a very recent
discovery--
is that dyscalculics have
abnormalities particularly in
both of these areas, and maybe
particularly in the left in
older dyscalculics.
So they have abnormal
structure.
And also, the brain activates
in a different way when
they're doing number tasks.
Now, why should they have
abnormal structure or abnormal
activations?
Well, there are a number
of possible reasons.
We don't know all of them.
One of them is these
abnormalities seem to be, in
some cases, inherited.
One of things we do know is
that there are particular
genetic abnormalities that seem
to affect numbers more
than other cognitive
abilities.
So abnormalities in the X
chromosome seem to have an
effect on parietal lobe
development and also on
numerical abilities.
So individuals with a number
of different X chromosome
conditions-- like Turner
syndrome, where you have only
one complete X chromosome, or
Fragile X syndrome-- they seem
to have a big effect on your
ability to do even very simple
number tasks.
BRADY HARAN: How do you
diagnosis this?
How do you make the decision,
yep, that
person's got the problem?
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
Well, in the study that we
just published, we used
two criteria.
One is you've got to be
bad at arithmetic.
And it's important to note that
it's got to be-- it's
timed arithmetic that's
critical here.
Because there's a difference
between somebody who answers
the question, what's 5 plus 3,
with 8, and the individual who
goes, 5 plus 3--
8.
So time is a very good
diagnostic here.
And we also looked
at the ability to
just enumerate sets.
So how many dots are there
on the screen?
Now, how good you are at this,
even in kindergarten in one of
our studies, is a very good
predictor of how much
difficulty you're going to have
in learning arithmetic.
BRADY HARAN: What is it
about counting dots?
Counting dots seems to--
is it just because it's a good,
easy, dependable test?
Or is there something more
to it that I'm missing?
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
It's a very dependable test.
So if you're bad at it at five,
you're bad at it at six,
you're bad at it at seven,
you're bad at it--
well, up until 11.
In our longitudinal study,
that's as far
we've gone so far.
So it's a very stable
indicator,
so that's one reason.
The other reason is because it
links to the kinds of things
that might be inherited, the
kinds of things that other
species are able to do.
BRADY HARAN: What do
we do with someone
who's got it, then?
Are there drugs they can take?
Is there something
that can be done?
Or are they a basket case?
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH: No,
they're not basket cases.
But like dyslexia, what you
need is special kinds of
intervention.
So if they're not very good at
enumerating sets, it means
they don't have a very good
sense of the number of objects
in the set.
So if it's a set of five, not
very good at enumerating it
means they don't have
a very good sense of
what fiveness is.
So what you have to do is you
have to have interventions
that target that particular
weakness.
So you're given lots of practice
at enumerating sets,
linking that enumeration with
the symbols that we use for
sets, like the word five
and the digit 5.
And in fact, you can relate the
number of dots to how long
it takes you.
So unsurprisingly, you might say
the more dots there are,
the longer it takes you to
give the right answer.
But there's a very reliable
result, which we've known for
at least 50 years, which is that
up to about four dots,
you're very accurate and
you're pretty fast.
And thereafter, it takes you
about an extra quarter of a
second for each additional
dot.
And this is sometimes called
the subitizing range.
And that's called the counting
or estimating range.
And there's a point at which you
go from one range to the
other range.
And that suggests there
are actually two
processes at work here.
And we know, actually, from
some recent mirror-imaging
studies that we've done, that
there are in fact--
there's a separate part of the
brain that does the subitizing
range from the estimating
range.
BRADY HARAN: At how many dots
does it become reasonable for
someone to make a mistake?
Because I feel a lot of pressure
with the dots.
And if you put up 30 or so,
that would take me a
long time to count.
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
Right.
This is a very fair point.
If you give people unlimited
time and you tell them they
have to be accurate, they'll
just count them.
And they'll be pretty good
at counting them.
If you give them limited amount
of time, then they can
count them up to a point.
So for example, this
is from children.
So it's taking them seven
seconds to get to eight dots.
But if you gave them less time
to do it, then of course
they'd have to estimate.
And it looks as though for big
numbers, you use a somewhat
different process than when
you're doing an exact
enumeration.
BRADY HARAN: What do I
do for big numbers?
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
Well, you make an estimate
which is based on extracting
various visual properties from
the stimulus.
And there's now some brilliant
work done by Marco Zorzi's lab
in Italy, where they've modeled
how this might work.
But for numbers up to about 9
or 10-- for some people, it
might be a bit more--
there's a way in which you kind
of can enumerate even if
you're not actually
verbally counting.
BRADY HARAN: I feel like when
I'm doing it, like when you
showed me the six,
I counted three.
And then I kind of made a
little split and counted
another three and added
them together.
Is that a normal thing?
Is everyone doing that?
Or are some people counting
them one by one?
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
Dyscalculics will
count one by one.
This is one of the interesting
things about dyscalculics.
They're very bad at doing the
estimating, using the
estimating strategy.
You can do it with
three and three--
we've done some work on this--
but you won't do it
on three and four.
So you won't say, well, there's
a group of three and
there's a group of four.
It doesn't give you
any advantage.
For reasons we don't fully
understand, having two
visually separable groups
of the same
number is an advantage.
But having two visually
separable groups of different
numbers, for reasons I don't
understand, doesn't give you
any advantage.
BRADY HARAN: Well, you
know more than me.
I feel like with seven, I would
count three and four.
Or maybe I would do
three and twos.
I don't know.
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
Well, come into the lab for
some tests and we'll see
what you really do.
BRADY HARAN: There's
two there.
PROFESSOR BRIAN BUTTERWORTH:
Yes.
Correct.